foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the break room this is
our daily live show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy fandom news
that you need to know do not adjust your
monitors it's boys
uh it's hot and we got the hot boys
for you all today coming up on the show
today there's no white smoke coming from
the WB Discovery chimneys they haven't
found a new one yet uh we talk about the
Venom we could have had not the Venom we
deserved
if Star Wars is going old school baby
but first we gotta get to this lovely
panel we have on the show today I'm
Brandon Barrick who cares across the
table from me we got koi Chandra
last day of risk oh that's right that's
right uh we're all afraid of what's
coming down the corner especially Tom
Michaelson hey yes I'm very very worried
I got some hand sanitizer here in case
things get dirty yeah we're drinking
we're drinking out of weird things today
because of some bugs I'm not missing I'm
not happy about uh next to me Tommy Beck
told ladies and gentlemen what's up baby
happy NFL Eve by this time tomorrow I'll
be screening through tables just top
shelf off a food truck straight through
a folding table to the Chagrin of
everyone around me Bill's Mafia sleep
tight tonight because tomorrow we go to
wall you are my ride to d23 so please
leave me your card in your will uh can
you get a Dr DNR for Tommy becos I can
get his car don't worry I got you baby
I'll take you to d23 I'm gonna sleep 48
hours after the Bills game all right I
love to have it uh we already got some
super chats rolling in thank you so much
we love to have your all your super
chats Nick Morris saying happy to be
watching a live stream on your
man when I turned 40 in 22 years I I I
don't know but I'm looking forward to it
I'm looking forward to it uh before our
Redemption today in preparation for d23
we are doing our spiciest d23 takes but
you know just to give get to give a
spicy take okay you got to eat something
spicy that's right when you give the
take uh they're making me eat on on the
break room today that's my favorite
thing to do don't worry we got a bag we
got tons of hot food options over here
lots of noisy things to eat uh this is
Ghost Pepper pop ghost pepper popcorn
straight from the Bass Pro outlet in
Ontario Canada
smacking jelly beans so for so for every
hundred dollars in super chats that we
get uh one of us or a couple of us we'll
throw a poll in the chat we'll eat
something spicy you know have to do it
if you don't want to do it I demand that
you do we're doing it okay and then you
get to drink water out of these insane
objects this is lotion
uh I'm worried that it is lotion Tommy I
am wearing it so smooth oh my God my
throat is so lubricated what's the SPF
for your intestines uh so yeah every
hundred dollars in super chats it will
give a spicy take while eating spicy
food how spicy uh but before we get to
all that ladies and Gentlemen let's get
to the headlines
live episode of er energy
[Applause]
oh they did it twice for the east coast
and the West Coast how exciting uh our
first headline Dan Lin will not be
joining W Discovery as head of DC film
and TV uh the two sides couldn't just
come to an agreement and the
negotiations have ended without a deal
coming to fruition Brandon if I may yeah
sometimes you lend some you lose some I
can't believe
I can't believe I allowed that at all
it was right there when it comes to this
situation variety is saying that Warner
Brothers Discovery is continuing its
search and insiders are saying that
there is no immediate urgency to fool a
job no no no media urgency as Warner
Brothers Studio Chiefs Michael Deluca
and Pamela Abby are seen as Adept
stewards of the current slate of DC
projects oh hell yeah this means
verified they're fine they're not
rushing this guys yeah we think that's
true at all two sides about this yeah
yeah one don't rush because it's very
important and you need it to be the
right yeah you've got to make a good
pick so Optics are hey this is great on
the other side I think they need a
really like they've announced the Batman
too which is right and that penguin is
still going on yeah Harley Quinn season
four the rest has been a lot of like
they need to win Joker Joker too yeah we
got some casting news in Joker that we
do yeah I'm not a fandom being like I
feel like they need a counter to fandom
not happening they need like a big like
and this is like the thing so I think
that they shouldn't rush but also maybe
they'll take your time and what is the
what is their criteria like do they need
do they need someone to come in with a
plan or are they just saying you're
smart and you've made movies because
Kevin feige like he actually has a plan
you know I think that's what makes him
who he is so they also need someone that
can be there Steve Jobs they need
someone that can present they need
someone that knows the comics they need
someone that knows the fandom they need
someone who knows producing it's not a
one job someone that can do the 17
things it is of the stuff that we don't
even know and understand so I can't
imagine the interview process of like
okay what of these checklists so I'm
hoping that whoever these producers are
have a lot of say in what they want like
I'm hoping for the sake of Dan Lynn and
whoever else the reason it fell apart is
like they want more like they like I
hope whoever gets this gets what they
deserve because it's a it's the
lifestyle yeah right you're not gonna
live you won't see your family right for
like a decade yeah so I hope they get
paid we're getting obviously close to
halfway to a spicy take and I'm really
scared I cooked that popcorn today I
made it in the microwave and then I just
opening it it almost knocked me it was
dangerous it was dangerous uh I imagine
DC you know they say they want to have a
10-year plan I think they have like a
here's what we've got for the next
couple years please come in and help us
right we're open to hear what you want
to say I'm sure they want to hear
Superman in that conversation I'm sure
they want to hear lots of Batman in that
conversation uh but I bet they're open
to it we know that Emma Watts is also
told to be in talks for this but you
know I it's interesting that this work
out with Daniel Lynn that's fine the
fact that the story got out it made me
think that like someone wants the public
to know that this is happening yeah do
you think this was like Daniel Lynn was
never really gonna do it but like let me
get my name out there and raise my stock
a little shoot now his interview with
whatever other Studios yeah yeah I was
like right right and it works for wb2
because they can be like hey we're
working on it we're working on it
what's the deal with the contract okay
there it is everyone in the chat uh
they've got my number okay if they want
to reach out if the C in DC becomes
school I'm available
Chad are you asking for me to be the
lead
but speaking of DC news we did get a
casting update just came in a couple
hours ago Catherine Keener has been
added to the cast of Joker full of juice
uh we don't know what role she has but
deadline saying quote a major role major
role John called it as the warden
already he's calling he says she's so
great I think she's going to play an
aged Pamela Isley
okay agent sounds right yeah Kevin
Keener is beautiful I'm just saying by
movie standards where they have to be
like 28 years old to be a villain like a
hot young villain Kevin Keener is
gorgeous if she played like a hot older
botanist that was locked up for
poisoning a bunch of people that were
trying to take over our lap but you know
you do it deconstructed the way Joker
did where like she's not magical or part
plant she just poisons people with
plants so she's a serial killer as well
so over in Arkham I want to know is she
going to sing we know that Brendan
Gleason got added last week is he gonna
sing yeah like I want to know if
everyone's singing listen to this
penguin and her as Pamela oh my God
yes I am and I do crime I do every time
I do a crime I do it for you oh I'm the
penguin I'm the penguin boy I am well
look I'm right the music you're right
here first guys I think we've got you
know we lost Stephen Sondheim but we
gained a tummy back yeah oh my gosh oh
my gosh how lucky uh so well we're
excited to hear more about that but next
headline uh the director of both the
Shazam films David F Sandberg he
revealed in an Instagram post yesterday
that Sony uh reached out to him to
direct Venom initially way back in 2018
but he ultimately chose uh the Shazam
instead he said he read a draft of the
script which means they were probably
pretty serious about it uh but he was
also kind of like developing Shazam and
you decided to go with that he was kind
of more interested in that uh David
Sandberg he's directed some like horror
movies this is a really cool yeah I
think he if he literally got it uh that
would have been interesting he did say
the Instagram post like quote I thought
vendum Venom turned out quite good
though which is one person
I like parts of Venom I like parts of it
I enjoyed Venom I actually own I know I
last or two weeks ago I was railing uh
to rallying for physical media I own a
copy of Venom on four God bless you I've
got my true fan wow
problem I mean if anything Venom
introduced to my household me walking
around going like Eddie I don't know
which my wife loves I'm like I know what
that movie was yeah and but his take
would have been cool because he was able
to balance like that amblin sensibility
of the 80s with modern horror and I
really liked it into Shazam I'm glad he
said what's his name because Shazam is
very impressive but oh yeah think about
how much more aggressive yeah that might
have been with him
lighter like kind of family-oriented
like imagine that CEO horror scene and
Shazam but with Venom biting off
people's heads
oh yeah
works in the industry so he knows how
hard it is
to do this stuff and yet he puts us over
the hundred dollar limit so now we have
to eat something spicy all right we're
pulling to see who's gonna give a spicy
spicy take uh we also want to think
match one for three who sent in the
Super Chat who said he'd like to
formally announce that he has officially
been keeping it Gucci dimucci oh nice
match thank you and thank you for paying
to keep it Gucci dimucci appreciate it
uh Max Savage sent in a Super Chat bring
on the spice with a couple of pepper
emojis uh and we told Joe was saying
another greetings from Poland Wednesdays
are for the boys that's right uh how
exacting you guys are doing the best job
on the internet so keep it going pause
pause draw warming now I'm sure I said
that wrong take that Wikipedia we're
doing the best job I've heard that in
Poland Wednesdays are there Saturdays oh
no they really rip it up on a Wednesday
little do not uh correct me on that if
I'm wrong back me up baby I'll hit you
back
J rhyming Lee uh Senator Super Chat
saying live you guys are the freaking
fracking best Jenny Davis asking you
about Zach if you watch the show
yesterday we had the wheel of redemption
up Zach got silly stringed and it
started to destroy his neck and skin
he's permanently yeah he's still
bleeding out in the bathroom so the fact
that you once knew is not the jack that
is is around today he'll be back but
we're not sure if we have to put a cloak
over him yeah he might become like the
Phantom of the break he looks like the
crab feeder oh yeah
Doctor Doom next week oh yes
all these great takes on him
yeah guys guys throw some uh deformed
faces in the chat if you have it uh free
girl our girlfriend girl says hi koi Tom
my baby boy Tommy love you great girl
Brandon oh boy hot take Nikki is a
scroll girl I am with you oh great girl
I am you and I are on the same page I
believe Jessica is also on team Nikki as
a scroll I'm gonna you know what I I
brought it all the way from Canada
all the way from the you know it's a
good Bass Pro outlet when they have a
pond in the inside the store and this
Bass Pro outlet is no different so I'm
gonna eat some of this ghost pepper
popcorn give us a spicy d23 taste yeah
no
[Laughter]
oh no
[Music]
no
right tongue is falling up to twice the
size normally
everybody's hyping up
you have your lotion don't forget okay
everybody's
everybody's off oh my God this is
my throat's closing up don't die please
everybody's hyping up Star Wars yeah
Marvel at d23 you guys are missing the
thread it's all about 20th century films
baby oh yeah oh it's just Avatar oh it's
just Avatar
no it's not
there's more films that are going to be
announced that are going to make you go
I forgot those movies existed oh I think
the biggest splash of d23 is gonna be
made by 20th century films
not Star Wars lucasfilm Lucas Arts
George Lucas Lucas these nuts oh 20th
century will be king you think this is
and queen and Prince and Duke and
non-binary royalty at d23 okay okay okay
I mean it is all Disney so they win
either way but I like it I like this I
don't feel good
I said I would extrapolate or be funnier
but I don't have it inside don't do it
please we need you to stay here
all right as Tommy dies let's go on to
our next headline uh the Star Wars
series The acolyte you may have
forgotten about this well they've added
a new actress her name is Jody Turner
Smith uh in an undisclosed role there
she is there uh you might have seen her
most recently in Queen and slim uh in
the series Anne Boleyn uh if you don't
remember you're like what's acolyte I
remember I'm talking about that at some
point uh acolyte is going to be set
during the end of the high Republic yes
uh it's like a mystery it's been
described as like a mystery slash
Thriller that's what uh Kathleen Kennedy
called it uh except during the end of
the high Republic which is like uh
I'm so sweaty it's like 300 BBY to like
82 BBY oh just before The Phantom Menace
when the Jedi want bbls bbls they're
doing butt lifts oh yes there are 300
bazillion butt lifts you know when you
fly back from Brazil after that you have
to like sit inverted in your seat on the
airplane
after butt lifts and tell me I'm wrong
and when you see them upside down you'll
know who to think anyway let's get to
form faces in the chat for those Jody
Turner Smith is also married to Joshua
Jackson oh okay oh great you know what
can we believe that that is a family
okay one of those things so it's taking
place before the end of the high
Republic It's pre everything we've seen
in like the Star Wars series uh it's
being uh the head writer and showrunner
is Leslie Headland who created the
series Uh Russian doll but also Rayne
Roberts is kind of like a co-developer
co-creator with her she rain Roberts
works on like basically every Disney
Star Wars project all the movies
including Rogue one and solo uh all of
that so everything you guys love she's
worked on uh and we've also Amanda
Stenberg is already in the cast yes uh
from uh bodies bodies bodies right
bodies bodies bodies and why uh
why you hate or something like I forget
the bodies bodies bodies and then
absolutely destroying that one critic
from The New York Times that's true
that's true uh so yeah that's acolyte I
don't need a butt lift Olivia and have
you seen my butt it's big enough for two
and it's lifted high like a monster
truck uh monster trucks in the chat for
my ass
so we know that also that this has to be
a a Jedi or Sith type show because it's
a lightsaber slash through the logo
right yeah
yeah the sets are pretty pretty under
wrapsody like the Jedi are Riding High
we haven't seen that really in Star Wars
no and this is the Jedi yeah if you
played like Knights of the Old Republic
this is like kind of after that before
uh Phantom Menace so like oh kind of
tucked in there I like this idea tons of
new stuff please I want to hear the name
Skywalker yeah I don't want to hear any
Skywalker names and I do not want to see
tattooing I want I just want the end of
it like this baby
his name is Kenobi
that's
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what you get with an all-male break room
for Bill Burr impressions
and our next headline and this is
probably our most important headline
folks so please
please get ready for this news uh the
red is now flowing morbius is on Netflix
oh yeah turn on your second screens
right now and start streaming uh more BS
take the chill out of it because ain't
nobody getting it on but morbius is on
yeah you are dialed in for 89. turn off
your phones turn off the lights don't
touch me I'm watching more videos stop
putting your hand on my small of my back
I'm watching Morpheus there's no
chilling during this Netflix we are just
pure Netflix pure Netflix it's morbid
time ladies and gentlemen get ready yeah
uh uh another big news story today
though uh it's being reported that black
panther wakanda forever is they're doing
some reshoots they're taking place right
now they just started they're gonna go
for about a week they're in Atlanta you
know the the capital of making Marvel
movies hell yeah they're in the home
base they're in the Death Star uh so
this is this is the kind of big news as
we all know all of these Marvel movies
have baked in uh reshoot times right
that's part of the thing it's actually
really short this is destroy it right
like this could be a scene or a like
moment that EDR needed to get together
it's probably not stunts right right
yeah
no way they could do us like they could
maybe do one Thirty second action
sequence in a week maybe I also think
because these movies are puzzle pieces
like we said they do have to build in
the reshoots if only for because other
things change about other projects that
impact the movie so there might be a
name of a character that is going like
they're gonna move someone's actions to
a different character in a later Team Up
movie so all of a sudden they have to go
back or not go back they have to make
sure that they've done their due
diligence and do research because that's
why you get whatever you six weeks from
Black Panther yeah so it's like we're
they're starting research because things
are probably changing with like the
Fantastic Four movie also different
announcements coming in 23. yeah so I'm
wondering if there's an announcement
that's going to affect like did they
just cast someone they were about to
announce it and maybe this is the end
credits scene for that that yeah they're
trying to have come out finally cast
Mojo yeah I hope so uh well we were
talking yeah probably an end credit
scene right that makes the most sense
the least destructive to the work you're
already doing yeah they did that like
the week of the movie exactly like they
didn't have it at the premiere because
they filmed it after the premiere system
right and get them all there that's why
Chris Evans was doing this because I
already had a beard yeah exactly
exactly so six weeks out they can do a
lot with that and so it's probably just
a casting thing with d23 right well
there's all that news that it seems like
Matt shackman is gonna be the director
of Fantastic Four and that kind of came
about in the last two weeks so if he's
in there now if he's starting to make
some casting decisions there's always
been rumors that based on the comics
ties of wakanda and like that Bay Area
that this could be a tie-in to like
Fantastic Four maybe a Doctor Doom or
maybe like a Reed Richards we did see
there was like a casting notice that
went out for a body double yeah and the
body double the two main things was they
had to have like salt and pepper hair
and they had to be able to run no no no
stress okay you don't have to have your
own built-in stretch ability okay that
is a little rude Richards he's got a
little salt and pepper here also I got
my oh you go ahead no no you say yours
well we were saying it could be every K
Rod yes which leads me to my deepest
darkest bombshell Theory okay getting a
Hot Chip for this Ross is Doom
oh dude whoa Martin Freeman is Dr Doom
that's that's wild why not he's been
inside learning all about the Avengers
Initiative the whole time helping put
out fires in Civil War he's secretly
from Liberia changes his voice
[Laughter]
I go by the name Jackie Daytona now uh
okay now we're slippers uh do you think
there's like a specific reason that
they're doing these reshoots in Atlanta
if
if for no other reason that like they've
shown how they can pop up a green screen
anywhere and recreate anything I mean
why go why go to the Mothership they
might be using one of the sets they've
built for like right like they could be
like the throne room yeah or they could
have known that they waited to get this
actor maybe yeah that's the case and
they wanted to film it in the spot so
they kept the sentence and then you just
bring them back to the set that's easier
yeah maybe they're also overlapping with
something that's about to film or
filming right now so they already got
all the players there so might as well
just bring them over there yeah come
over next door yeah come over next door
and film this thing real quick well
we've seen where uh post-credit scenes
are sometimes directed by the director
from the next movie like that scene uh
uh where Thor is being interrogated by
Doctor Strange right that was taken
right out of Ragnarok and popped in as
like an end credit scene when they
caught Bucky and they have his arm in
the metal press popped right out right
so yeah if they are filming something
right now and they've already got people
there it does make a lot of sense to go
to Atlanta uh I think it's good it's
nothing to worry about uh it's just
interesting that the story came out I
think as everyone's just watching that
place like a hawk uh we have done a
couple of polls out there don't forget
to send in those shower redemptions to
make Tommy eat something spicy again no
it doesn't have to be any guys it could
be anyone give a spicy steak we did ask
which film you enjoyed more Venom or
Shazam and it was split 50 50. wow 50 50
splits for Venom and Shazam people who
identified with Venom vote twice
Shazam folk twice it's both about people
who are two in one show yourself Billy
boxing uh which Star Wars series are you
most excited for between Andor and the
acolyte 60 said Andor 40 said the AC
light I think that's fair we've seen
some cool stuff from it I'm very excited
for Android that Variety article got me
hyped for Andor I'm very excited for it
uh will you watch more because now that
it's on Netflix no 50 yes 49 they're
missing one percent yeah it's an hour
and a half of your life and that there
are some turning another fun about it I
think they thought no man yes yeah that
doesn't make sense actually I think I
think actually we're getting new results
100 and 100 yeah someone's hacking our
poll system yeah uh and then do you
think we'll see Dr Jimmy and black
panther wakanda forever 58 saying yeah
because we're going to see here which is
right I think Vampire Doctor do you
worry about that
too big though I want to make a
fantastic calendar is going to be so
good we won't notice if he's not like I
can be excited leading up to it and then
that movie looks like every frame of
that trailer is so staggering I'm not
gonna end that movie in tears going like
get on this dude but if he's there we'll
be like also nice all right yes yes I
agree uh another uh news item we wanted
to talk about today we got uh a new look
a new look he's sweating he's gonna die
folks some of it is the lotion oh okay
I'm good thank God we got a new look at
Nick Fury from Secret Invasion and
you're gonna love this folks it's from a
Funko Pop hell yeah toy review why are
Funko Pops telling us so much uh why is
it so spooky well this is Frightmare on
fun Street time okay
that most important news we've learned
right now but it looks like you know
it's undercover Nick Fury walking around
nice one of his eyes taken over by the
White Walker well you know that's his uh
Patrick plain white it's kind of milky
white I thought it has like a little bit
of gray in it it kind of is like split
maybe I could get all those colors are
they still not then let's hear animation
trailer yeah they played it oh people oh
yeah because this is whatever they
showed a Comic-Con they have not put out
yes got it so this outfit is in the
trailer oh okay
coming out from my heart on Android news
uh we have Android news at the end of
the show we'll definitely get to it
don't worry don't worry about it um uh
uh so yeah you've seen you've seen this
you know it's in the trailer that's
great news that's good to know uh but
it's a it's a recurring it seems like
it's gonna be like and it fits the tone
the trailer itself was my biggest
surprise from Comic-Con because I knew I
was going to be excited for the things
we knew yeah and secret invasion was
like middle too excited this was maybe
the best cut trailer I've seen from
Marvel since like Facebook oh okay it
looks this was a full trailer it wasn't
just like it felt it wasn't like a scene
or it wasn't yeah like it felt like a
story based and it felt like all of the
things I loved about secret Invasion
story in the comic books but also
totally it felt like winter soldier it
felt like that's what I was gonna bring
up like it felt like the elevator scene
throughout the trailer it's lots a lot
in Winter Soldier Nick Fury you know he
fakes his death spoiler alert uh and he
kind of goes undercover for the rest of
that movie and posts that movie because
the Hydra falls apart or uh Shield
what's the difference falls apart in
that movie right this looks like going
back to that even though the last time
we saw him he was on involves the sword
and like sure working with them so I
need for him to go undercover again is
very interesting I'm assuming there's a
betrayal from the Scrolls that he needs
to hide out because he doesn't know who
to trust right and so like this feels
like I love those paranoid Thrillers
from the 70s and like the Harrison Ford
of the 80s yeah this feels like that to
me okay so it's very much that like yeah
scroll scroll get on get off my [ __ ]
it's interesting because the winter
soldiers where they revealed that he had
that milky eye yeah yeah now here we
pick up password so yeah exactly so now
he's probably needs it to you know
around exactly exactly two-factor
authentication yeah fingerprint and
dirty eye I like it it's a great I did
recently watch uh uh Winter Soldier I do
love that scene uh Robert Redford so
good in that movie oh yeah he does the I
think Robert it's kind of like oh come
on it's dumb as hell I can't believe
that worked it's great uh so yeah I'm
hoping we get some secret Invasion news
on Disney which we'll be at uh well
we'll be here on Thursday tomorrow
I'm hoping they put it on Disney plus
day because I feel like d23 is just
gonna be so much so much two-hour window
for like you know so many things yeah I
don't think they'll rehash what do you
guys think we might hear about on
Thursday like what would be their big
news give me a Hocus Pocus 2 trailer a
full trailer give me the hug release a
full Hocus Pocus two Trails cowards I'm
on the show Sanderson sisters
uh is anyone here a virgin to like the
candle no definitely no that that's a
funny weird thing that's like a big part
of our children's movie is like how much
they bring up he's a virgin his sister
is ragging him about being a virgin and
the other girl's like all about
virginity six ways to Sunday
there's no part of me I've had I do what
we call the old tenor with these hands
take on the entire top 10 of the New
York Knicks
sausages
Edward sausage hands enjoy it well
Alaska this is the last all guys the
last one so I'm not gonna be on the show
anymore
that's a spicy tank is there anything
else you think we might see on Disney
plus thing I think they're gonna keep so
much the like they're gonna be an
animated accidents
werewolf by night where are you werewolf
by night yeah that's so soon what are
you who are you they could maybe do a
couple of uh you know teases of things
like maybe this Moon night too that may
or may not be happening right now yeah
maybe that's what they were filming
there was like a quick teaser a little
teaser I was thinking back to last
year's uh Disney plus day which I think
was our first one they might have done a
second one I I don't remember it might
have been the first so last year's was
just like we were really excited for it
and the first 12 minutes 300 tweets were
like Nat Geo shows and all this other
stuff which are great we love it Chris
Hemsworth Limitless Limitless looks
incredible Christmas it will not be
appearing
yeah
everybody knows
do not expect it yeah yeah but I think
there could be I hope they have some
like trailers at least it's like a
visual message I'm Chris Hemsworth
playing Mad Max
oh nor it's d23 I forgot to go there and
I'm so far away I guess I'll send in
this cell phone message kind of like a
cameo oh I'm Chris Hemsworth I hope
you're excited about my new show
Limitless your Nord you [ __ ]
bro I liked it uh thank you to our super
Chatters GSU Eagle sending in a super
chat it's my birthday today so let's
spice things up with a bit also where
are the booty beads merch at you cowards
uh the FCC won't let us make
a happy birthday GSU Eagle all the time
and graveyard good old pray the guard
setting in a 16 Super Chat
it takes to put us over that 200 Mark I
think that will that will put us over so
yeah we'll get a Poco in the chat for uh
frantically clicking buttons right now
spicy he's got pulls he's got spicy
why don't we uh don't vote for me you
jerks vote for someone else while
they're bowling to pick Tom and make a
meeting someone else's turn uh Tommy why
don't I have a mug why are we drinking
out of this dumb things someone in the
middle of the night
over the weekend stole all of them
replace them with these novelty objects
now Zach and I both kind of got a little
bit of a like hey come up with some mugs
you know maybe uh come up with something
you gotta make merch first yeah we could
not agree on a design artistically we
were we were very so we were very
separate places so for artistic reasons
we separated uh and we both got a chance
to pitch design uh options to Philip
please take a look at how that went
now
super guy I thought you said you wanted
to have lunch I did you didn't drink any
food for me the pleasure is watching you
die I'm getting in the mug here and I'm
not talking about this gorgeous face I
want mugs on the epic hero shop and I
want these mugs to be so big people
can't possibly drink from them we've
been talking on the break room right we
we sit you guys are still on the break
room yeah yeah we do the show every day
Phillip still okay pivot
so Tommy I think has already met with
you I don't think his ideas are good and
I don't think he's pitching you good mug
ideas I just wanted to make sure most
most of what he said was not related to
Mud Goodall what's the highest point in
the world your mom I know the memes it's
like a guy and his girlfriend but he's
looking back at a different girl right
like I get that thing you know uh gifts
I understand gifts dog Circus the mugs
fund the circus oh my pitch is what if
it says it's morbin time no stop let me
give you one last idea it's a coffee mug
okay now I'm on board it's also an
Amazon Alexa
if you say that you will cover the cost
of the entire inventory we carry we'll
make it what if
guys mugs are like dual bugs do a
short-term contest where by the audience
purchasing those mugs they're kind of
voting for which becomes the permanent
break room mug brother can you spare
some change
what is that mug that he has in his
hands that mug is aesthetically gorgeous
well here's the trick that man's not
homeless he's not even blind he's
billionaire philanthropist T Michael
bechtold and he's about to drop mugs
that are going to blow your back out you
don't want too topical of a mug sure you
want a mug Evergreen yes an evergreen
mug right because you're gonna be keep
drinking out of it forever the break
room's never going to go away
and it's still on right now
yes I can do this I could do this
I think they say mandatory fun on them
and on the and on the handle
they say
big dicks hot chicks
this might be worse than Tommy's idea
there's only one way to find out all
right anything else other than the
phrase mandatory fun on the mug I have
some squiggle lines some fun shapes
I got me the squiggles you're [ __ ]
fire time
[ __ ] out of here that's gonna be so fun
great mandatory fun
I'm wearing the exact
ly exact as I'm wearing today uh Cry for
Help sure uh let's be honest Zach is uh
I've made no secret about this Zach is
one of my oldest friends in La I met him
and Brandon uh right around the same
time almost I would say 15 years ago 14
maybe years ago Zach's lost the step
fatherhood has ruined his brain oh my
gosh he is now thinking about things uh
in survival mode he is flight I am fight
I will fight for you oh my God to get
you the mugs you deserve here's our
little coward boy mugs his are mugs for
people that maybe on January 6th we're
at the Capitol right oh my bugs are for
Patriots of the old-fashioned way flying
the red white and blue
for Liberty and freedom and brother and
Sisterhood in every personhood my mugs
are for everyone Zach's mugs let's just
say this they found a few of Mar-A-Lago
did you poison that Silly String
yesterday in an effort to kill your
competition during this mug contest I
can neither confirm nor deny that I
doctored up the string oh my gosh now
Coy's got to give us a hot take okay so
I know where we're at in the show and I
want to make sure things got sampled so
I went Doritos oh my God this is flaming
hot lemon yeah I'm gonna chase that with
a scorching cheddar oh my God what is
this tape gonna be I'm gonna I'm gonna
cap it off with some some ass kicking
jelly beans habanero oh man Corey you
can't die on the show please I you know
chat will rebel against them boy we
spent so much money fixing the bathroom
the koi boys in the chat are gonna be so
upset yeah if you die my spies your dick
is that Kevin boggy is gonna come out
and she's gonna wear them a d23 hat I
was gonna say d23 and so we're all gonna
be like what's the Hat gonna be like
yeah he's like wait for the house yeah
yeah you're gonna take off that hat and
it's gonna where the 23 was gonna be a c
oh it's gonna be like I bought it all
and then we're gonna get the giant
shared Universe of DC and Marvel wow so
the reason
didn't get the job is they got Kevin
he's like having fun I got GC 23 coming
to you this weekend oh my gosh he's got
30 minutes every other week to talk
about DC and he he booked he booked it
out that is a spicy take that is a
really spicy cake oh you like it it's
marinating your face is turning a little
bit yeah it's cooking it's like
individual beads of sweat battling down
here all right we're adding in the
scorching chairs oh my God there's so
many oh you can't Corey for your
children oh my God sweat has biceps my
mouth is watery
oh my god oh no oh no more of course not
this voice he chips uh I do like that
spicy take uh it's very good 23. all it
was missing was the fact that Kevin
feige will announce the Jubilee Trilogy
oh yeah all right with the company come
on we gotta raise another 100 bucks so
Brandon can talk about that with spicy
with ghost pepper not spicy it's it's a
true it's a true take okay
it's like suicides at Taco Bell let's
see what happens when I put all the
spices thank you to all our
superchargers max143 saying make me a
mug to blow my back out you bet we will
they go on sale tomorrow right there
yeah the mugs will be revealed and on
sale tomorrow and by the way you can buy
mine or you can buy Zacks but I will
know individually addresses and names of
anyone who buys that and I will be
making house calls if you feel me uh
Jeff brennerman sending a Super Chat
saying Nova question mark do you think
Nova this is not in describe you you
think Nova will be a series or a film I
actually think
Nova [ __ ] cares oh my God oh my God
filmer series I think film what about
you Coy I think Siri's leading Series
right yeah I think Avengers is gonna be
the movie that brings them all together
I think we get Noba on the TV I think it
might be an immersive one of those books
where you can put hair on the bald guy
and then erase it over and over again
hairless Herald yeah yeah yeah I think
that's probably what it is uh Ragnar
sloth Brock great name sending yeah how
do you guys feel about Power Rangers I
feel great about that yeah uh I was
still warm inside I was less than that
well I'm sorry I was less than fulfilled
with the Power Rangers the most recent
Power Rangers film the first Power
Rangers movie is great no notes
I don't like the turbo I was fine with
that too that was fine with Dinosaurs
I'm fine with mystical ninja animals
yeah but wasn't it turbo was kind of a
combination of the old old original
American Power Rangers and then the
newer one didn't they have some of the
older characters in the Turbo Power
Rangers movie I think they did yeah
someone carried over yeah
Jason will show up in any Power Rangers
project you have but we love the Power
Rangers Jason come on the show uh and
katoot had a spicy tank uh which I think
you'll agree with koi Disney made secret
deal Warner Brothers ACU amalgam
Cinematic Universe 23. okay so PSA
people people can't wait for it this
medium this
you know when you're traveling and you
get the food that you can eat at home
but they may use real ingredients in not
America like actual spice yeah um this
is that as a jelly bean my insides are
like this heat is cooling but now I feel
like I'm being microwaved like the like
the middle of me is hot and the rest of
me is like cooling yes it's a journey
um all this uh talk of the MC or a a AC
ACL reminds me of the time I blew out my
ACU okay uh Dr nasty put Mongoose
ligaments in my knees they're not great
yeah no it turns out you need man
ligaments yeah put men ligaments in the
chat
[Laughter]
that's right
um oh man you know what that operation
that was elective yeah you know what's
Not Elected why mandatory
screw this yes that's right the graphics
so nice I could really use some milk
with ice to cool but it's still
scorching by esophagus
the straight lotion oh nor I'm out of
ocean foreign
hit the graphic again
yes it's mandatory fun where I get my
three closest friends in the whole world
together for a little bit of
non-optional fun it's Wednesday it's
hump day it's wacky it's fun you know
what we do on Wednesday on Wednesdays we
wear pink uh no we do She-Hulk
predictions and uh we've got our
She-Hulk fantasy league uh ripping and
roaring baby it's week four there's some
standings arguably I have 15 I think we
bumped that number up to a 20 but uh you
know I'm not gonna nickel and dime we're
all pretty close trash has 20. yeah
you're doing well trash you don't have
Jessica to vote for this week so you're
gonna have to pick one you are gonna
have to side with one of us now sorry
suckers we did ask uh we had as for
usual we asked three questions and we
asked everybody on the show and some
other new rock stars luminaries to make
their predictions first question
the She-Hulk Smash and this will be
based on episode four it comes out
tonight midnight uh West Coast does She
Hulk smash and I'm talking get it on
that's the only smash that I understand
yeah yeah I I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
no because I I don't think
I still feel like they're afraid to pull
the trigger a little bit with that I
don't know I could be wrong but I don't
think this episode she smashes I'm gonna
say no uh and we're saying we're also
saying this is She-Hulk smashing
she-hulks it's not Jennifer Walters
smashes it's just purely a thing that
happens She-Hulk smashes fantasy points
so I said yes oh okay yeah I did not say
Noor I said yes yeah cause you know we
saw that part of the trail with her
carrying that guy after that Tinder date
maybe this is this happening episode
four we'll see well good on you uh I
think she's earned it I think
she's now developed it's like Jennifer
Walters we're not counting yeah
because I want her to have a positive to
be in She-Hulk because we've had her
feel demoralized by being like Showboat
around the house yes
I want She-Hulk to get hers and I want
her to orgasm like a whole can oh my God
what are these the Netflix shows I don't
know
that clap and scene I want all the
Neighbors
on this evening
my mom watches this show so I don't I
want to be very delicate about this but
I do have some questions about the
anatomy
and the science we're not doing that on
the all-mail breaker we're not doing
that conversation okay like there is
some contractions that would worry me
we'll have we have to weigh attention
break it off if she gets particularly
angry break room after dark yeah all
right nice these will all be on my blog
uh the tomsquad.com also I would like to
ask uh simulu's opinion if you're out
there come on the show come on come on
the show
in Sherman Oaks
all right second uh prediction
we need to predict what Cameo we think
will be happening now we have Jessica
GAO telling us no more cameos besides
the ones you already know I don't
believe it so we're gonna but we are
gonna play Within her rules Twisted
playground okay and we're gonna say you
know basically the people we've already
seen uh in the in the promos who's
cameoing this week uh Brandon what did
you say I went with the support group I
think we'll see Emil's support group
this week oh nice I feel like that's got
to be coming soon now that he's a free
man I I agree with you I also said the
support group good good call good on we
do good on yeah we do have an office hey
welcome to the table
we're gonna have a leapfrog or maybe for
a frogman I don't know what we're
calling him
for sure
Hulk I'll twist my knickers into a
ponytail if she is I've seen him do it
holy prank okay so mine I want to just
give credit to the printout here um okay
so actually I'll just fold because I
want to make sure we we maintain
suspense but uh I've got
I I wrote stiltman which was that was
not an option
not an option yes I I stand by it to
such a level I'll predict the rules okay
you think so man I mean I feel like
still man is in the Zeitgeist right now
he's a topa for sure everybody's
everybody's thinking about still and
finally we had dates that uh we believe
this is the episode that's gonna focus
on uh Jennifer's she-hulk's dating life
dates I think we're combining both of
them okay that's right I think it's
whoever they go on dates with either
form is okay we said over five and a
half spoiler alert everybody went over
we're all thinking
like one of those those bets of FanDuel
where they're like if the Toronto
Raptors score one basket tonight you win
ten dollars in FanDuel credit not a
sponsor very Niche gambling point that I
just made not for everyone I apologize
uh buy my mug tomorrow don't buy Zacks
every dime of proceeds from Zach's goes
towards making a kid sick okay mine go
towards healing them Zach will simply
make them sicker he's like he's like the
March of Dimes only he's marching dimes
over to those babies houses
dropping a dime on those babies that's
right uh uh yeah definitely check out
those uh mugs tomorrow check out soon
video tonight if you're gonna watch it
tonight go ahead and hit that like
button that's right uh if you're ever
gonna watch it hit that like button if
you're not gonna watch it also hit that
like button thank you so much uh and
thank you to all of our super Chatters
today Abraham's sending in us uh Super
Chat saying Smash and pass I mean we
might see a little bit of that on Shield
I don't know uh thank you Tanya Tyler
for your generous Super Chat uh Atomic
frog sitting in a Super Chat saying
really hoping for some Tron and Elita
news what about you guys I they're
making a Tron show right I love the Tron
Legacy movie I just uh on that on the
D20 yeah
I want them to get back into that it was
so cool yeah it's a very cool lore
confirmed like even let it was back and
stuff a lot like years ago yeah I
thought they were gonna bring back Tron
yeah
for a while but yeah I mean that was the
cards for sure yeah I really enjoyed I I
enjoyed Tron legacy I like that in uh
Culver City you can see Flynn's arcade
yeah in that one building
um across from the Culver City Hotel uh
we don't we're nowhere near there so if
you go down there you won't see any of
us because we are in Santa Clarita but
uh yeah that's really all we're voting
on who whose predictions we want before
we can say goodbye to all these trash
bags and send them down to shoot uh my
bin buddies my bag hags my uh receptacle
crew my receptacle uh gang so name
yourself classic trash uh Christmas
trees in the chat because it's almost
Christmas season
visit visit a visit a local Spirit
Halloween store well you can uh because
before you know it those are all going
to be Christmas Tree Shops uh why
doesn't someone do that why doesn't
Spirit Halloween own a Christmas
decorations
already but they should have like a
seasonal store for other things like the
same company
and also guys if you got a chance say
some prayers for Zach uh his skin is
falling off the bone every week you guys
don't vote for me and every week I get
more inspired to Surge to the top
leaderboard I came out on top of the
poll I'm gonna I hope I do you guys well
tonight let me tell you what Brandon on
top you could do worse you could do
worse thank you man yeah 26 if I see
still men on that show tonight I will
burn this place I'm gonna laugh at all
you I will burn this place to the ground
uh we want to thank you all for joining
us today on the break room it's been
another beautiful hot day here in an
undisclosed location in this
apologies to Andor we did have an
Android segment we can't get to it today
I'm so sorry uh uh go ahead and join our
Discord uh if you're 18 years or older
you get to make clips of the week which
we're totally gonna do again this week
we promise uh you can send in voicemails
you can talk about the show you can do
all that stuff thank you guys for tuning
in today thank you for all your generous
super chats uh we hope you have a great
rest of your Wednesday I almost forgot
what day it was uh and we'll see you
here tomorrow right here on the break
room live and in person have a good rest
of your day latest Gators goodbye